We're here tonight to celebrate the career of a brilliant young man: comedian, actor, artist, magician,
And... some would say a smooth pimped-out player from the streets that knows how to get his.
Please welcome...
I want you to check this guy that's very very funny
From Washington DC
And the Grammy goes to...
So I bring you now...
Dave Chappelle
written by Dave Chapelle
It's all relaxed. Thanks for coming back since you guys have been so good to me tonight
I feel like I owe, you know, this this next piece is about the real Dave Chappelle's personal
It's actually very personal but here it is
That was real midnight I was playing that's a felonious monk song
One of my favorite musicians because his timing was so ill every comedian is a stickler for timing and
Thelonious Monk was off time yet perfectly on time.
You should study it, as an aspiring comedian or inspiring musician it.
You should study it.
I was going through a real tough time man, like just readjusting and
My mom bought me this time magazine with Bill Cosby on the cover. Kyle's been inked
I mean the guy had a lot of stuff in common like some of the quotes he would say and I just remember
Like after reading that stuff I put it down
And it was like I'm a big community every time there's a black celebrity in trouble
Neil's of the beliefs that I never think he's guilty and the reason he thinks that it's because I never think they're guilty
It's just how I roll me at first. I didn't believe it. I was like, these people are obviously
Trying to destroy Dr Cosby's rich legacy
When Cosby got sentenced, Chappelle and rock called me back to back like both of them
Fucking legitimately sad
I felt bad for them.
I was explaining to my younger family members, you know, I
Like who he was at one point?
juxtaposed to what's happening now, so it's astounding and I said obviously
Bill Cosby is a hero to me and she doesn't know what it feels like to think that your hero might have done something so
heinous all my heroes
even murdered by the government
registered sex offense
My wife fun will probably be like, oh my god, Dave look there's George Washington's the father of this great nation
I'm gonna go shake his hand. I'd be on the other side like run nigga George, Washington
It's tough to see your heroes fall let alone
Be a villain you like them because he wrote the Declaration independence and all that shit.
We hold these truths to be self-evident
Men are created equal
Go get me a sandwich nigger or I'll kill you
Liberty, justice for all
this is my impression of the founding fathers of America
When the Constitution was being written hurry up and finish that Constitution nigger, I'm trying to get some sleep
Now, you know
I always talk about whatever is close to your mind
It's like the trip lighting man joke is just something that's painful to me that you just try to make funny trunks
We started talking about variety shows
We want to do some of those real personals. It was just hurt. I don't know
It was just the word personal kept coming up. I
Started doing drugs when I was little just like you
I grew up in the crack epidemic. I'd tell jokes about it
Was it was not a tease? It was like a crack bomb a gun up like
like DC during a crack epidemic
Was probably one of the worst cities in America
Everybody I knew sold cracks only God knows
How many people were smoking crack that made a real big impression over? I see one crackhead trying to break into somebody's car Landon
It's truck calling me. I tried to stop I said hey
Looks at their
Stop and now there's a opioid epidemic
Are they treating the opioid epidemic the way that they treated the crack epidemic? No, this is a national health emergency
Well, we were coming up with police by the National Guard addicts were criminals. She was like a little suspicious a little suspicious
Every dead black person the police found as crack sprinkled all over
These white folks look exactly like us during the crack it
So now that your community is getting destroyed is the whole nother ballgame. There's a huge window of empathy
Y'all wanna party what up
Here comes a deep-water. This is fucked I shouldn't even say to the fuck. It's not politically correct to say these things
I'm gonna say something that I'm not allowed to say I know it sounds fucked up. I'm not supposed to say today
I'm gonna get cancelled for sure
I don't think people pay money to see a guy speak precisely and
carefully most other you have a
Responsibility to speak recklessly. He's a comedian who's kind of trying to jab the lion
You know who's trying to test the water way back on the second episode. I did this piece about the a crack addict
coming to a
Hey Drug, Awareness Week at a school. I got a lot of complaints about it
I got a lot of letters about a lot of people said I was insensitive
So I brought them back again to the show. If you say to a comedian you can't do this
I guarantee you they will immediately do it
Against two of Chicago's finest MC you give it up for common and Kanye West I
Walked in the crib. I've got two kids and my baby mama late Oh
Comedians and musicians were like this every comic wants to be a musician
every musician
Banks, they're funny
It's a very strange relationship, isn't it? All these people will we all have in common?
I think we all have very personal message that they try to get across first of all
I've known Dame for a long time. He's a genius. He's a real comedy genius
I think that the angley's seeing things flow is about the vision that he sees and all this shit
They talk about all the news about how divided the nation is. I love them I support
Remember bitch, you clicked on my face. I don't have to agree with everything that he says, I just trust the person that meant it
but the
Haitians say all that shit, but I
For one find solace in the arts
I don't have to agree with all the art consumed but it helps me understand how I actually feel about it
At 19 the champion is the youngest comedian to ever appear on Star Search. He's from Washington DC. Here's Dave
Chappelle
Thank you guys very much like when I'm on stage I get real happy up there
But maybe that's the only time in my adult life that I feel like myself
Standing up there, you know
I mean like gladiator and then Mike's is on him and you look down and everyone's looking at what you like
And it's all of these smiles around you and they get dressed
They put perfume all this stuff and they're going to see your show. It's the best feeling man. I love stand up
That's why I love my art floor cuz I understand every practitioner of it whether I grew them with Matt
I know where they're coming from. They want to be heard. They got something to say there's something they noticed
They just want to be understood
Love this job
It saved my life
These people are at least as influential to me as my family we fight and we Pharsalia
Jealous of each other we get mad at each other
But my life wouldn't been what it was without each and every one of them and I consider them my family
It was way bigger than hip Bob
That's looks like kind of like that was our work those my niggas write down
I deal with me this week was like this. So nothing that will come between them. You're watching us
I appreciate that Justin. I want you to know fuck everybody. They should pale understand
It's always a really gratifying experience making these videos that take a more
Documentarian look at a single artist whether it's Chappelle Quentin Tarantino or Bo Burnham delving into an artist body of work always
Provides a window into their soul. It's also why I love dantana Leaders class creating a modern cinematic documentary with soul
It's an invaluable guide to crafting a story out of someone's life experience for me
It alone made my Skillshare membership worth it skill shares catalogue of thousands of classes in film business
Technology and more make being a member a no-brainer no matter what your interests are, but see for yourself right now
You can get two months of Skillshare for free with our link
Click the link in the description and get two months of unlimited access to thousands of classes for free
Plus it helps us to at no cost to you. And as always thanks to our patrons who make this channel possible. Thanks for watching